[Music]
hi welcome to games of the week for
those of you who are joining from my
choice which was like five minutes ago
I'm glad you stuck with us last last
lecture we talked about English opening
my game from black side this is also in
Gibraltar both games both my game and
one close game happened in Gibraltar but
different years and slightly different
writings and this game white was the one
who had the upper hand most of the game
but in my game I was the one who had the
upper hand as black so also they are
slightly different in the opening even
though there's they share a lot of
similarities they're like just different
variations so without further ado let's
jump in oh it's one cow against pragna
nonde it was like three days ago all
right be good
all right so c-45 this is for some
reason called the four nights variation
I assume just because the four nights
come out so there are different ways to
play here you could go for g3 you could
go with III g3 the idea is that you
would play d5 as black most likely and
now after Bishop g2 you just put your
knight on d6 again usually probably you
do have the option of taking in this
specific situation and then efore but
typically this is the structure that you
would get into you would have this part
these bishops here and Black's game is
in Queen side whereas White's game would
be in like center and more more center
and slightly Queen side more mainly for
defense and keeping it all together but
so another variation to play with white
is this e3
now if Eitri what black can't really do
these D files anymore so you kind of
have to play Bishop before Queen comes
to c2 again this is also theory and
after d6 so black Black's plan is kind
of clear black wants to play short
Castell still undecided about where this
bishop should go from c8 but one thing
that's kind of obvious is this knight on
f6 is very misplaced so you kind of will
try to bring it here so it's protecting
more squares and dominating this side
and since white has two bishops white
would most likely try and open up the
center of it maybe d4e for stuff like
that so these are the general ideas to
follow
and in the game 1 cup lady 4 and after
castle g3 was played I'm serious simply
because just bishop wants to come to g2
castle and d4 because probably if d4 now
it might be a little too early because
94 is possible and then there is this
route 8 and it's simply not the best
idea to open up the center where your
king is still in the center so g3 97 as
mentioned earlier this Knight wants to
come to c5 mr. G to night c5 again d4
doesn't work yet because of simply
taking and then rook e8 so Knight c5
whoops
alright now after night c5 white could
probably simply make Casto but why
decided to go with Knight h4 so the idea
is that after Knight is for now if it
was white to move again why it could
play d4 right because if d4 now that
Knight takes e4 at the end of the
variation doesn't work because Bishop
simply takes on e4 and there won't be a
rook e8 pinning the Queen there won't be
a queen on e4 to be pinned so 19 to h4
I'm not very familiar with this specific
variation but it kind of makes sense for
black to try and do something in the
Queen side because White has a lot of
weaknesses and ideas to work on in the
Kings side so specifically probably
coming up F for d4 these are some of the
ideas that could be worked on
and in the game pregnant under I hope
I'm pronouncing it correct I think I am
was played a six now Castille now take a
little bit of time and tink what should
black do I'll be looking at the chat
okay we have some of my ideas with f5
it is blacks to move so f5 doesn't work
simply because just logically it's not
the best idea to open up the center when
your opponent has two bishops also f5
you would kind of be giving up the pawn
which is not something that's worries me
that much because you could just come
take it back but your York erytim of the
game would kind of be distracted so that
is why I kind of remember how I talked
about moving like thinking about the
Queen side so think about I still keep
thinking about doing stuff and the Queen
side
you brought your f6 Knight all the way
to c5 to the Queen side so you should
try and follow it up with Queen side
ideas
okay I do like the idea with Bishop e6
Queen d7 but the problem with Bishop
this Bishop e6 specifically is that
white could simply play d3 and then
whenever white is ready to play d4 like
right now whoops right now d4 it
wouldn't work because simply take take
and Knight can take but whenever white
is ready maybe Bishop to b2 maybe Bishop
to e3 then d4 is very dangerous because
attacking the knight on d5 coming
Oh mr. Carter is right the right move is
be fat also been jamming Benjamin
Benjamin enemies he is also right also
Paul
Oh a lot of people are saying it great
yeah b5 is the right idea
now b5 if white takes it blacks position
is really nice
this trick is open attacking this guy
over here black has a clear idea how to
proceed in the Queen side whereas so if
not take what if what should White's do
so we don't want to take no C takes b5
what else
okay so we have d3 ideas a lot of d3 910
five it's a little early but the ninth
eventually we'll jump there okay
remember how I was talking about two
bishops and opening Center and stuff so
think about it move not D 3 D 3 is and
the problem with d3 is that what black
could just take and your pawn structures
are really kind of um I'll go with the
word unpleasant so maybe try another
more active move
okay I do see okay Paul you are right I
think the first one to say d4 might be
might overlook something but d4 is the
right move to play because now that
simple ad for your opponent kinda has to
take it now that when you take back if
Knight takes d4 here you do have to move
the Queen so you have kind of have two
good options Queen to d2 or Queen to b2
which one would you prefer to play d4
was a very good move so for those of you
who said it's good job for those of you
who had it as a candidate move still
good job for those of you who didn't
think about it you have a lot of
opportunities to see good news
we have bunch of quindi twos
a lot of clean D choose one so far Queen
B - okay I'll give it another minute and
then I'll say it
ah now Queen c3 be careful 90 - check
okay
ah so queen mmm we still have a lot of
Queen D twos we do have so the I think
the problem is that after Queen B - you
are worried about okay that's not a
valid scare and I did see in never mind
okay so Queen B - what's happen in the
game which I have found what I
understand was a novelty but let's look
at what if Queen you went to D - if
Queen d2 ninth pack goes back to c6 e 5
for example [ __ ] about everything is
exchanged and this was actually a game
between Gilderoy ruling and Peter
Svidler in 2015 which ended in a draw
but in this game Queen B - was played
which to my understanding again is a
little bit more active and keeps a lot
of opportunities in the middle game
whereas in Queen d2 as we saw followed
by for example e5 and e6 d6y this is
still okay there's nothing wrong with it
but since you have sacrificed a part
ideally you would want to keep the game
very active and give your opponent
chances to make mistake so after Queen B
- 96 so now if it was black to move what
would you want to do as your next move
again it's wise to move but I'm just
asking for you to think about your
opponent's if it if you just play it
something like King is 1 or something
just super chill
what would your opponents do
yes go Tracy let's see if I have anybody
on the live chat
okay if it was black to move black would
ideally want to place this Knight to e5
to have domination over this square and
all of these fun puns pawns under attack
so now that is white we know what's
black once you kind of have to try and
stop it
the best way to do it is to play e5 and
the idea is also the fact that your
Bishop is kind of becoming a super hero
over here you're opening up your bishop
you can't really take back with the
Knights because your rook will fall so
your knight is under attack is black so
your next move should be pretty much
something to defend the knight and now
as white I get to keep opening the
center so just compare it to here the
move rights before playing d4 compare
this position to this position even
though white has one pound less the
position is very open this Bishop is
like a super hero
this Queen is very well placed this
night could try and jump on to f5 any
day and this bishop is the only thing
that could be better in this diagonal
ideally and even though you're not
entirely sure where to place your rooks
it's not that hard to come up with a
good Square for them whereas for black
the problem is that none of wax pieces
know where to go probably your rook c8
will be coming up just because this
knight is pinned and you want to unpin
it but where should you place your queen
what is this bishop doing in d7 so
in the game at this point one car is
clean d2 I'm not sure if I would have
played it to be honest because I
probably wouldn't have seen it ideally
I'd like to think I would but I think
the idea is very simple Queen d2 is
simply attacking this guy and next one
we want to play Bishop beat you maybe
queen c3 and go for the jugular
so after rook c8 C takes b5 Knight comes
to e5 because the knife was free now
take on e6 and if the bishop if it was
white to move again white would have
most likely started going to use this
advantage of this punch so maybe
something like this should be true wood
won't work anymore because of 9 c4 maybe
something like Bishop e3 to attack the
knight that's attacking my pawn maybe I
could even try for something like a 4 to
take away squares land such as b5 from
my opponent but anyways it is black to
move and black did play Bishop e5 this
is a very this was for me very very
interesting game and it was kind of very
challenging to actually find the right
pose so if you can't find the exact
right move don't beat yourself up just
try to understand the ideas and keep in
mind that we are looking at super
grandmasters who do played this game
literally three days ago so
after Bishop comes to be 5 so this pond
feels like it's kind of falling right
but be careful because your rook on f1
is under attack rook d1 seems to be the
best move especially because this this
point is under attack so if you were to
simply take my pawn I could simply take
your pawn and then we would go to an
endgame that it's better for white white
is a pawn up and has two bishops this
sons this is also a passed pawn it's not
a double con so Bishop comes to a4 to
attack the rope to kind of distract it
rook e1 no nice comes to d3 it looks a
little scary right there might be some
ideas with rook C to F to pawn so what
do you think white should do I mean
specifically in this position but also
overall for example you kind of probably
are going to suggest moves that you
would move the rook but after you move
the rook what are some of the ideas that
you see on the board and one suggestion
keep thinking about how blacks pieces
are most of them kind of like hanging
they don't really have good protection
and keep thinking about that idea I'll
be looking at the chat so we could I
will see suggestions there as well
okay so people some people want to
sacrifice the exchange okay so one thing
about sacrifice that is usually correct
is when you want to sacrifice something
it either has to be positional or you're
doing it I was like a real sacrifice not
just an exchange I there has to be
positional that you would gain something
very specific out of the position or it
were simply like an attacking attacking
Dynamics sacrifice but the thing is if
you play something like rookie 5 now it
simply doesn't work because black pieces
are way more ready and way more active
than your pieces so like that's kind of
the main problem if you were to
sacrifice the e1 rope you would be
giving up one of your few active pieces
if your bishop on c1 was somewhere else
and it was active and the rook on a1 was
also active then yes it would have been
a good place to think about a sacrifice
but it's not so I didn't really see any
any any suggestions on the move that was
actually playing down the game so in the
game they put one cowboy to keep one the
idea is very simple because my opponent
falsified records seats you and then
take on my pond so I simply go back and
I protect my pawn so the thing is one
thing that I thought about was so
probably here after Bishop e5 rook t1
Bishop a4 what if I just played ring f1
and then I thought well my opponent
would just repeat it because well
I don't want a repetition so probably
that is why after Bishop a4 rookie one
was kind of like luring your opponents
to play this Knights d3 to block that
Bishop e5 idea and now we're after rook
c2 Queen III one of the big ideas is
this f4 coming up because if I get to
play f4 I'm attacking your 95 and if you
move the knight on e5 your knight on d3
would be falling whoops
so that is the big idea and so the move
that black does should be something to
protect this d3 knight or to move this
d3 nights in the game my opponents well
not my opponent black one cows opponent
played 95 which I completely understand
and agree with the problem is that f4 is
not the only idea that's why it has so
why pawns to play f4 and go after this
guy right so ideally well I won't be
complaining about winning a piece but if
black were to not allow this had to
happen and play something like 95 the
idea of a7 still is very valid so the
Queen on e3 is also looking here to
protect the a7 pawn and now it's getting
a little scary right
a8 new queen protected by the bishop on
g2 so Bishop c6 is pretty forced because
if not Bishop C 6th and 8th were to be
Queen Bishop exchange
and now Queen comes to f3 this was very
interesting
positionally because you just simply
exchange the bishops off and instead you
placed your queen on that big diagonal
and one other thing that we kind of
heard a lot about but we don't always
apply it is the to centralize your
pieces especially your Queen given the
chance and right now this Queen needs to
be centralized like you could move this
Queen to for example a tree and still
keep it behind that pond and still have
nice ideas you could put it on h5 and
try to go for some attackee
ideas but Queen d5 is the best one
because you're centralizing your queen
you are attacking this night you might
have ideas with Bishop e3 you could keep
thinking about pushing this you could
even think about something like this so
in the game pregnant on the plate 92
check King G 2 and here black had one
move that would have reduced White's
advantage slightly but so here why it
has good advantage it's not winning it's
simply advantaged but black had a move
to try and decrease that advantage tip
nice eatery was played in the game and
that is a not to move that was best so
try to think about the best move and
also think about what pieces are not
working and how to activate them I'll
still be looking at the chat and hope
for some cool ideas
okay oh yeah it is black to move and we
do have somebody found the rights move
to people nice what
nope well yes it is true and they did
play it in the game but it's not the
best one Mattel is right mr. Carter is
right
so I'll just touch on it very briefly
because we still have they still have
kind of played about 20 more moves but
just to keep it simple coin a5 was the
best move and the idea is quite simple
you just want to take out this pawn that
is very annoying you and also you might
have some depending on what white would
do the there could be some ideas with
coming to probably c3 it's hacking again
really depends on what what good whites
do but cool so in the game after Knight
c3 Queen comes back to f3 keeping it
close to the Queen keeping it close to
the King and again keeping this pawn
protected supported and now in the game
they play a pregnant White Queen a8
Queens could be exchanged off and it's
not a bad move to follow but Dwight has
a better move think about it this way if
you were to exchange the Queen's off you
would automatically give your opponent
the gift of one tempi that this route
comes to a eight keeps attacking on a
seven and now your pieces are still a
little disoriented whereas if you were
to play a move such as Knight f5 now if
the Queen's were get to exchange and if
like something like rk8 first off you
could consider and move such as rook e1
to go for eight or you could simply
think about alright I'll take this pawn
I'll be happy or if you want to be even
sneakier you could play Knight d4 now
the rook is kind of trapped isn't it so
that is the idea behind the Knight f5
that if you were to exchange the Queen's
off I am both attacking your opponent
and coming to d4 and your rook would be
trapped
so Brooke went to a rook shouldn't go to
a8 cuz the rook fool the other group
fool would be trapped so then the game
queen takes a a seven was played and
here Bishop f4 was played but it's not
the most accurate move I'd like to give
you all one minute to try and find it it
is kind of alright let me see I don't
want to give up the move but okay the
tip that I will give you is that your
queen and your night are kind of looking
at the Kings side aren't they so think
about that
[Music]
that's a very simple move queen g4 it is
a good idea but you have something more
feisty
Oh Mattel good job
let's see if I can read
I'm gonna give my Arabic right you're
reading a try I might fail I apologize
for the pronunciation in advance also
here at I'll must he must appear at you
are also right dish of age six
Sydney real right for those of you who
said this over six and tired of episode
six good job mister mystics is not an
easy move so like if I were playing this
game because up until now the game has
been very positional right you just keep
trying to advance your pieces push more
and you're not really thinking about
sacrificing your pieces just yet
so it is very understandable if you
didn't really consider this move there's
nothing wrong with that also White's
position is good enough to be able to
convert the advantage to a win without
special h6 but what is chest without a
little tactics so if Bishop h6 you were
to take queen g4 and it's see you next
game but they're so like kind the only
way to defend it is with 96 and if Luke
whoops
if 96 now this might be a real threat
so whoops nope we do not want to
sacrifice more pieces so the way to play
it is to simply play and move such as
rooks e1 so you're kind of sacrificing
but not really you like your bishop is
just they're keeping the threat but at
the same time you're activating your
other pieces so if rooks take see one
group take c1 I'm attacking your c3
Knight
and if you were to move the night for
example take on a tube I could simply
try and bring this route to the attack
so that is why Bishop h6 is such a nice
smooth and it is again perfectly fine if
you didn't think about it so I put it as
your candidate moves Bishop f4 was
played in the game at 27 a super
grandmaster with a rating of 27:58
didn't play Bishop h6
so don't be too hard on yourself after
this level for very positional move
black played 96 which is again a very
good move attacking this active Bishop
and honestly this pawn was about to fall
regardless so take on d6 Knight to g5
now remember how I talked about
centralizing your scent rising your
pieces on everything especially your
queen now how do you want to do that
yes
okay so the best way to try and
centralize your queen is to put the
queen on c6 even though it's a little
scary to have the queen against this
rook this Knight is kind of pinned so if
you move the knight rook goes for free
so even though Queen d3 is nice the move
Queen d3 is a interesting you kind of
have to be careful with giving up this
is this diagonal to your opponent so
Queen c6 is the best move and in this
situation partner nanda realized that
there's he kind of has to try and
exchange the Queen's off of the board
because if not this but this is under
attack and pretty much next move this
night could become under attack now it's
III is coming on the board so the best
way for black to try and survive this is
with Queen a8 White has to take and now
keep in mind that this pawn is under
attack
so simply play a tree to keep your pawn
now for black the best try is to keep
the Knights in the center and for whites
the best try is to try and exchange this
guy off because this is very very
annoying for white and quite strong for
black see how this trick is kind of
dominating and paralyzing White's hand
it is it would be very nice if this rook
was exchanged off right so just play
your c1 take take now if black were to
take on d6 I believe that simply taking
it would be sufficient enough because if
rook takes on 83 there is a little
tactic here I will give you
thirty Seconds to find it
okay everybody's saying it's awesome
everybody's right 95 and it is kind of
bye-bye time probably something like 94
is also winning but 95 is just better
anywho so the best way for black to deal
with this week background is to open up
escape route for the king
how with g6 now check King up if King
were to go to h8 what do we do check and
then you can take or same applies for if
King comes to g7 so King Khan has to go
to f8 and now we get this disc oh I
don't want to say it I might have
accidentally showed it but just keep
thinking about it keep thinking about
it's actually not that hard everybody
would be able to see it right
take now if they can see you it's double
check so you kind of have to move with
the king and if the King were to go to
Center even though this bishop is under
attack and the knight is under attack
you could just simply remove the Knight
to e5 or f4 I prefer if I've just just
because of centralization and then if
take take so the king went to g7 I don't
really think that's much difference
between King he ate or G 7 g7 kind of
just tries to keep the squares on the
King side more so 9h for this is coming
up right
so black kinda has to take that fish of
an exchange take the take exchange well
it wasn't like direct exchange so now in
this point we have reached from a super
strategic game to a super getting a
little dynamic game and then to kind of
a theoretical endgame so the King King
King rook and Knight versus King Eric
and Knight is kind of you have to be
quite accurate to play it and for
example in the game pregnant 0.98 b5
which is a very logical move right you
want to just take on a tree pawn but
rook a6 was more efficient because they
are after rook e6 actually you can
simply see the difference between if
Knight b5 looks c6 cuts the king and
when you take it you get this check and
now that your king is even cut even more
so if you were to play route a 6 instead
of take on b5 instead of coming tv5 I'm
going for the take on a3
it would have been better and now blacks
idea is to play 95 and go for this pawn
right so it after rook a6 I don't really
want to get super deep into it because
it's kind of interesting because if it
was black to move and black were to just
take this and keep his King slightly
active it should have it should be a
draw and draw a endgame but the problem
is that white can simply play a four and
now when the rook takes you could try
and play rook c6 and be cautious that
district e4 is kind of a blunder because
of this fork so this is their
interesting idea that if your opponent
like plays a move that's trying to
prevent your big idea like rookie six
preventing the idea of rooks e6 you can
still try to come up with creative ideas
to follow up with that instead of like
lot of us would want to try an activator
knight activator king but a4 is the
right move to keep with your main idea
of ruling rook cutting the king and also
distracting black's rook to achieve that
so Knight d5 and in this situation
requests to c7 probably some checks
coming up rook F 8 defending the pawn
now it's the time to bring in the King
and start marching on the King side so
King comes after E King comes to e3
the other thing to keep in mind most
likely won't it's something like ideally
you would want to do but most likely it
won't happen is that see how this Knight
is cut off if this light was on g6 it
wouldn't be as easy for whites to try to
win the game but because this Knight has
kind of cut off white can actually try
and keep the Knights cut off so still
keeping the night cut even if the knight
tries to come out a little brighter f3
not playing the knight to escape and you
still want to play something like 96 now
now you push the pawns probably the key
H would have been slightly smarter and
trying to go for like something like
this but this this should be winning for
whites regardless would have probably
just made it harder so King goes to h8 h
5 you want to put that pawn on h6 and
kind of suffocate the King and you're
not drilling a rush you're just taking
your time and putting your pieces in
better places and now with the knight on
f1 this is the final move think about
how the night is completely cut off
knife can't go to e3 g3 Knight h2
doesn't make sense because of King g3
and just find this one move and black
will resign
keep in mind that Knight can try to
escape from d2 the key word being trying
well thank you easy easy yeah
chess is fun
so all of the moves that you're
suggesting will will win but it's about
finding the most accurate for you and
the most annoying for your opponent that
would make it kind of easier
ah yes Anna you are right Pedro right
I think Roxy too is also pretty accurate
but it's better to keep the rook on the
seventh rank so yeah we are having a lot
of nice suggestions about 357 so I think
yeah thank you rook d7 is the right move
so now white could try to simply play
something that group do you want to pick
up the knight or why it's good first
play h6 and like wait and kind of make
the opponent a little bit more miserable
and then try to pick up tonight but it's
kind of nice that this Knight see how
here the night was whoops
way too far here the night is still cut
off still cut off still cut off again
and up until the last move the knight is
just cut off so another idea to keep in
mind
don't keep your Knights on the corners
and last ranks cuz they get cut off
really easily yeah that's all I have for
today
unfortunately wang hao didn't win the
tournaments in gibraltar but i do
believe he scored the second place and
franklin andhe is one of the upcoming
new rising super grandmasters from india
and i do believe he is a teenager I'm
not entirely sure about the age I want
to say 14 but I might be wrong and yeah
so these are the people to keep an eye
on for we'll hear a lot more about them
coming up and I'm glad you guys enjoyed
it hopefully you enjoyed it
so yeah until next time
[Music]
you